[Applaus]
ohne reue voller schuld weil sie
hundertfach kinder sexuell missbraucht
haben müssen die beiden haupttäter im
fall löste viele jahre ins gefängnis
windenergie in der krise die branche
schlägt alarm und will hilfe von der
bundesregierung weil deren klimaziele
sonst kaum erreicht werden könnten und
blick in die zukunft in berlin eröffnet
ein museum dass uns das leben von morgen
zeigt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und abend in allen und
schön dass sie bei uns sind geben sie
uns 20 minuten für den überblick über
diesen nachrichten donnerstag sport
natürlich mit dabei mit norbert lehmann
genannten von mir der fall hat
deutschland schockiert hundertfacher
missbrauch von kindern auf einem
campingplatz in lichte heute das urteil
hohe haftstrafen für die beiden
angeklagten 13 und zwölf jahre gefängnis
und anschließende sicherungsverwahrung
das heißt die beiden kommen
möglicherweise nie wieder frei der fall
hat auch schlamperei und behörden
versagen ans licht gebracht dazu gleich
mehr
im zentrum des prozesses die
heruntergekommene behausung eines der
angeklagten auf einem campingplatz mit
geschenken lockten der dauercamper und
sein komplize die kinder dorthin
erschlichen ihr vertrauen
der ort wurde zur hölle für mindestens
32 kinder viele von ihnen gerade mal im
kindergartenalter dort ferber andreas v
verbirgt sein gesicht mario s hält den
kopf gesenkt was sie den kindern angetan
haben falle schwer in worte zu fassen
sagt die richterin in der
urteilsbegründung
begriffe wie abscheulich oder
widerwärtig reichten dazu nicht aus muss
das wirklich vorstellen
die kinder wurden teilweise anal
vergewaltigt bei jeder gelegenheit auf
öffentlichen toiletten von baumärkten so
einen kindheit hatten die kinder in
andreas fonds heruntergekommen aber
hause auf dem campingplatz in lichte
wurden kinder jahrzehnte lang schwer
missbraucht sie wurden gefügig gemacht
mit geschenken und drohungen
die angeklagten haben ein system von
einschüchterung verlockung und drohungen
um sich im etabliert was eben dazu
geführt hat dass die taten so lange
unentdeckt bleiben konnten vor gericht
haben die angeklagten die taten
weitgehend gestanden
und so den kindern aussagen im prozess
erspart reue oder mitgefühl aber zeigten
die täter nicht mit den folgen des
missbrauchs kämpfen die kinder weiter
sagt der anwalt an
des mädchens das mädchen hat
schlafstörungen kann nicht einschlafen
im dunkeln verletzt sich selber hat
erhebliche probleme auch gehabt in der
schulischen entwicklung und sie ist auch
dann kamen das jetzt hier alles vorbei
ist das urteil heute bringt den kindern
eine erleichterung sie werden ihren
peinigern wohl nicht mehr wieder
begegnen
aber es bleiben auch nach dem urteil
viele fragen warum hat die männer
niemand gestoppt obwohl es hinweise gab
warum gab es so viele pannen bei den
ermittlungen der polizei und den
betroffenen jugendämtern wird in dem
fall massives versagen vorgeworfen
bei den strukturen der behörden müssten
sich viel ändern meinen kinderschützer
heute an die chronologie des falls und
was alles schiefgelaufen ist jetzt von
peter böhme kinderschuhe als symbol für
den missbrauch auf dem campingplatz in
lüfte stille anklage auf dem
straßenpflaster in hameln
von dort kam das pflegekind dass andreas
v nach löste in obhut gegeben wurde
damit gab es zwei zuständigen
jugendämter das in hameln in
niedersachsen und das in detmold in nrw
wo der campingplatz liegt zwei
zuständigkeiten da blieb vieles auf der
strecke im jugendamt ameln wurden noch
akten nachträglich manipuliert wohl um
falsche einschätzungen zu vertuschen
2016 da wurde das damals vierjährige
mädchen andreas v als pflegekind
zugewiesen gab es mehrere hinweise auf
kindesmissbrauch auf der partielle sogar
von einer mitarbeiterin des jobcenters
doch auffälligkeiten fanden die
jugendämter nicht und die polizei sie
gab die hinweise nur an die jugendämter
weiter verfolgte sie selbst aber nicht
als der fall dann bekannt wurde
haarsträubende ermittlungspannen in
detmold etwa verschwanden solche
beweismittel sicher gestellte cds aus
einem unverschlossenen raum wenn er will
innenminister rolle damals ist alles
macht mich fassungslos
und man kann hier nur von einem debakel
sprechen denn man kann hier nicht mehr
von versäumnissen reden man muss hier
von polizei versagen sprechen solche
fehler wie hier die dürfen nicht passt
wir dürfen auf keinen fall passieren die
pannenserie ging weiter das grundstück
der partielle wurde wieder und wieder
untersucht weil sich wieder und wieder
beweismittel fanden die vorher übersehen
worden waren
zudem etwa oder usb sticks selbst der
abbruchunternehmer fand noch was polizei
versagen sagte innenminister eine kaum
fassbare abfolge an versäumnissen und
pannen frage an dort ferber in
düsseldorf dort was sollen denn jetzt
die konsequenzen seien eine politische
konsequenz ist der
untersuchungsausschuss im düsseldorfer
landtag der jetzt seine arbeit aufnehmen
und erklären soll
welche strukturen zu diesem versagen
geführt haben es gibt auch personelle
konsequenzen bei den behörden
mitarbeiter bei der polizei und muss er
im jugendamt sind vom dienst suspendiert
worden andere wurden versetzt und es hat
sich auch noch etwas geändert beim
innenminister der hat nämlich mehr
personal gegeben zur bekämpfung des
sexuellen missbrauchs mehr polizei es
gibt eine stabsstelle im ministerium
es gibt eine zentrale auswertung von
bildern und videos im landeskriminalamt
auf mithilfe künstlicher intelligenz
es soll apps und hotlines für lehrer und
erzieher geben aber all das sind
einzelmaßnahmen das bislang fehlt ist
ein gesamtkonzept zur bekämpfung des
sexuellen missbrauchs auf landesebene
dort aber in düsseldorf fielen dank über
einen fall der immer noch nicht vorbei
ist
so fiel zunächst dazu in rom endet heute
eine wochenlange regierungskrise in
italien hat ein neues kabinett aus
populistischer fünf sterne bewegung und
sozialdemokraten regierungschefs
giuseppe konnte und seine minister
legten vor dem staatspräsidenten ihren
amtseid ab neuer aussenminister ist fünf
sterne schiff luigi di meglio
nachfolgerin des hardliners matteo
salvini im innenministerium wird die
parteilose juristin luciana lamotte vor
allem die sozialdemokraten wollen jetzt
einen gemäßigteren kurs einschlagen in
der flüchtlingspolitik und im verhältnis
zur eu
und in großbritannien wieder eine herbe
niederlage für den premierminister das
parlament brachte gestern abend ein
gesetz auf den weg das ist boris johnson
unmöglich macht einen braig cit ganz
ohne abkommen am 31 oktober
durchzuziehen
stattdessen solle der ausstieg auf ende
januar verschoben werden
jetzt geht es darum ob und wann es
neuwahlen gibt aus london diana
zimmermann
der tag begann schlecht für boris
johnson noch bevor er den israelischen
ministerpräsidenten netanyahu begrüßte
verabschiedete sich sein bruder joe
johnson aus der regierung haben es war
eine ehre abgeordneter zu sein und drei
regierungen anzugehören
aber jetzt ist es zeit etwas neues zu
machen der kleine johnson befürworter
eines zweiten referendums ging weil er
den kurs seines acht jahre älteren
bruders nicht länger mittragen will
ausschlaggebend war sicherlich dass der
21 seiner konservativen kollegen
entlassen hatte weil sie für eine
weitere verschiebung des austritts
datums eingetreten waren
das land möchte klarheit und
entschiedenheit damit wir die eu am 31
oktober verlassen und die kollegen die
übrigens gewarnt waren was die
konsequenzen ihres tuns sein wollten
haben leider für ein gesetz gestimmt
dass der exit verhindern will
expectation bald johnson will neuwahlen
den nächsten versuch startet er am
montag im parlament doch die opposition
will ihre zustimmung verweigern
bis es ihm wirklich unmöglich ist das
land am 31 oktober ohne vertrag aus der
eu zu führen
momentan fällt boris johnson eine
demütigung nach der anderen ein
aber früher oder später werden die
vorgezogenen neuwahlen kommen
und dann ist völlig offen wie die von
drechsel drama gequälten dritten sich
entscheiden
es mag noch keinen termin geben boris
johnson hat heute trotzdem schon mal mit
dem wahlkampf begonnen
der kurs des premiers kommt keinesfalls
bei allen gut an doch in umfragen liegt
die konservative partei noch immer form
und im vergleich zu jeremy kurbeln von
der labour partei geht johnson als
kompetent und damit zurück nach
deutschland die landtagswahlen haben die
machtverhältnisse in sachsen und
brandenburg verändert da wir sind jetzt
dreierbündnisse her denn mit der afg
will keine der anderen parteien regieren
ob sich das auch deutschlandweit
auswirkt wollte das zdf politbarometer
wissen luton winehouse hat jetzt die
einzelheiten
das ergebnis der sonntagsfrage für die
parteien weitgehend unverändert nur die
spd kann 2 prozent zulegen alle anderen
stabil oder mit geringen verlusten
trotz der kräfteverschiebung bei den
landtagswahlen gibt es also relativ
wenig bewegung im bund stattdessen
scheint der wunsch nach kontinuität zu
wachsen
fast drei viertel erwarten jetzt dass
die große koalition bis zum ende der
legislaturperiode hält deutlich mehr als
noch im juni
dazu passt dass fast drei viertel es gut
finden dass angela merkel bis 2021
bundeskanzlerin bleiben will nur unter
fdp anhängern ist eine klare mehrheit
dagegen mit großen führungsproblemen die
spd sie sucht neues spitzenpersonal und
eine kursbestimmung künftig mehr linke
positionen in der spd wünschen sich 44
prozent aller befragten unter spd
anhängern sind es 45 prozent
gleichzeitig findet eine relative
mehrheit die oppositionsrolle besser für
die partei die spd anhänger sehen
dagegen mehrheitlich vorteile im
weiterregieren
die erfolge der afg in sachsen und
brandenburg bewerten viele als
denkzettelwahl
insgesamt 78 prozent aller befragten
sehen das so und auch 56 prozent der afg
anhänger sind dieser meinung
das treibhausgas co2 muss reduziert
werden um die klimaziele zu erreichen
wie das gehen könnte dazu gibt es
unterschiedliche ideen in deutschland
die unionsfraktion hat sich jetzt
festgelegt sie will dass auch im verkehr
und beim heizen emissionsrechte
gehandelt werden müssen das heißt wer
sparsamer ist machtgewinn wir viel
ausstößt muss zahlen
das spd geführte umweltministerium
dagegen will den kohlendioxidausstoß
durch eine steuer verteuert
generell lautet das klare ziel für
deutschland erneuerbare energien
ausbauen
bis 2030 soll der ökostrom-anteil auf 65
prozent steigen
im letzten jahr waren es erst 35 prozent
vor allem der windkraft branche ist
ziemlich die puste ausgegangen
nach boom-jahren bis 2017 kommt der
ausbau an land jetzt fast komplett zum
erliegen
in berlin treffen sich heute politik und
industrie um das zu ändern weniger hat
mehr windrad riesen so nah am haus sind
für mensch und tier ein graus protest
poesie aus unterfranken hier auf diesen
feldern sollte eigentlich ein windpark
gebaut werden
stattdessen baustopp geklagt haben
bürger und naturschützer unter anderem
wegen gefährdete tierarten ein fall von
hunderten und einen grund warum der
windkraftausbau an land im ersten
halbjahr fast zum erliegen kam
es wird mehr geklagt und deshalb ist es
so dass wir daran interessiert sind dass
wir einen großen konsens zustande
bringen wie uns das beim atomausstieg
gelungen ist wie uns das auch beim
kohleausstieg gelungen ist der ausbau
schwächelt auch weil
genehmigungsverfahren lange dauern
ausschreibungen kompliziert sind und es
zu wenig flächen gibt auf denen gebaut
werden
darf für ärger sorgen auch
abstandsregeln wiener ein windrad am
wohnhaus stehen darf und in manchen
regionen fühlen sich bürger die
investieren wollen
gegenüber unternehmen benachteiligt wir
sind uns allesamt einig dass der
entscheidende faktor für akzeptanz nicht
abstände sondern die beteiligung der
kommunen vor ort und die beteiligung der
bürger vor ort sind das sind die
projekte die akzeptanz schaffen
im norden haben wir viele dieser
sogenannten bürger energieprojekte und
dort gibt es keine widerstände
es ist wenig konkretes herausgekommen
beim gespräch im wirtschaftsministerium
heute weitere gespräche sollen folgen
die bundesregierung steht mächtig unter
druck denn weniger windkraft bedeutet
die energiewende die klimaschutzziele
20.30 und tausende von arbeitsplätzen
sind in gefahr
viel zu viel wind auf der anderen seite
des atlantiks hurrikan dorian hat vor
der küste im südosten der usa wieder
zugelegt an kraft ausläufer haben
inzwischen nord north und south carolina
erreicht und auf den bahamas hat der
sturm immense schäden angerichtet
das ganze ausmaß wird erst jetzt langsam
deutlich die zahl der todesopfer ist auf
20 angestiegen m at wissen berichtet die
retter wissen kaum wo sie anfangen
sollen in der zerstörung auf great abaco
island suchen sie nach verletzten und
toten
hunderte von menschen sind bereits
ausgeflogen zur hauptinsel andere harren
aus unter den trümmern seines hauses hat
jim bell überlebt obwohl er in der
sturmnacht fest mit dem tuch gerechnet
hatte aber daran hat wohl deutlich mehr
opfer gefordert als bisher bekannt
adrien verrenkten brach sich ein bein
seinen sechsjährigen sohn jay hat er auf
dem dach vor den fluten in sicherheit
gebracht ein windstoß hat ihn vom dach
geweht warf ihn in das steigende wasser
wurde bisher nicht gefunden
die polizei sucht vermisste verhindert
plünderungen und hilft bei der
erstversorgung tim islands haus wurde
überflutet jetzt ist er von den vielen
hilfsangeboten überwältigt motorsägen
zählte matratzen nahrungsmittel die
versorgung läuft langsam an für 60.000
menschen
ausläufer des hurricans erreichten
derweil in der nacht charleston south
carolina und verursachten durch
unterschiedlich warmen luftschichten
mehrere tornados hier in myrtle beach
wurde niemand verletzt oder getötet aber
dorian hinterlässt weiter zerstörung bei
seinem zug entlang der küste jetzt ein
ganz anderes thema bei uns museen sind
ja eigentlich orte die sich mit der
vergangenheit beschäftigen mit dem was
einmal war
dass es auch anders geht lässt sich ab
heute in berlin erleben im futur ii um
deutschlands erstem zukunfts museum
wie werden wir in 20 30 jahren leben
antworten gibt es interaktiv zum
beispiel in einem lab zum ausprobieren
und experimentieren carsten behrendt hat
sich das mal angesehen wolkenkratzer aus
holz klimaneutral unser neues zuhause
und möchte ich computer mit der kraft
seiner gedanken steuern können dieses
gerät misst meinen stresslevel rosa
heißt ich bin angespannt blau entspannt
je wilder es in meinem kopf zugeht desto
unruhiger das gekritzel auf der
glasscheibe ehrlich
allein den gedanken dass sie gerade in
meine gedankenwelt gucken und sehen ob
ich entspannt oder gestresst bin sind
nicht beunruhigend das futur ii um bild
denkanstöße liefern für die große frage
wie wollen wir leben 58 millionen euro
hat das haus gleich neben dem berliner
hauptbahnhof gekostet finanziert vom
bundesforschungsministerium und partnern
aus der wissenschaft die eröffnung heute
mit einem freund der zukunft astronaut
alexander gerst
denken wir an das leben auf der erde
schon seit jahren milliarden überstanden
der homo sapiens existiert auch schon
bei 100000 jahre wir sind gute problem
löse wir sind gute strategie wir können
mit in sich veränderten
umweltbedingungen umgehen aber wir
müssen natürlich auch schauen dass wir
unsere unsere umwelt unserem planeten
bewahren
die simple botschaft in zeiten von
zukunftsängsten gemeinsam anpacken im
mitmachlabor selbst an der zukunft
basteln
ich hoffe auch dass politik das
wahrnimmt dieses haus auch wahrnimmt und
vielleicht den einen oder anderen
denkanstoß aus dem was wir hier tun
vielleicht dann auch in die politik
übernimmt der eintritt in das futur ii
um ist frei und der besuch lohnt für
entspanntes nachdenken über unsere
zukunft das war der große blick in die
zukunft jetzt gucken wir mal in die
nähere zukunft aber tanz wählst du
fussball
klare sache morgen abend in hamburg der
klassiker deutschland gegen die
niederlande das rückspiel in der
em-quali kleiner wermutstropfen
mittelfeldspieler leon goretzka fällt
aus bundestrainer joachim löw trotzdem
optimistisch im hamburger
volksparkstadion wollen sie den
positiven trend bestätigen
die ausverkaufte arena schauplatz der
nächsten reifeprüfung für das verjüngte
löw team das auf einen offensivstarken
gegner trifft
holland hat sich stark verbessert
fußballerisch extrem gut verbessert
gefährliche schnelle spieler
das ist schwer zu verteidigen mit
holland macht also von daher müssen wir
uns einstellen dass morgen die
konzentration hochhalten brand oder
werner werden den durch die verletzung
von sunny frei gewordenen platz im
angriff besitzen eine einsatzgarantie
bekam sehr knapp die deutschen
volleyball frauen haben das em
halbfinale nur knapp verpasst vor 10.000
begeisterten zuschauern in lodz verlor
das team nach sechs gewonnenen spielen
in folge gegen die polen trotz einer
couragierten und mitreißenden
vorstellung stand es am ende eines hoch
spannenden fünf satz krimis drei zu zwei
für die gastgeberin einer der besten
skifahrer der welt sagt servus
österreichs alpin superstar marcel
hirscher beendet seine außergewöhnliche
karriere und das mit 30 jahren keiner
vor mit so viel kraft willen und gespür
für schnee jetzt ist schluss nach zwölf
jahren im weltcup
es ist ein leben das man schlussendlich
dann wirklich mit vorher auf morgen
beendet herrscht perfektes thierry basis
seiner erfolge zweimal olympia-gold
sieben wm titel inklusive des
unvergessenen erfolges 2013 im duell mit
felix neureuther dazu acht gesamt
weltcup siege nacheinander jetzt will er
mehr zeit für sohn und familie die mich
gern mit dem klo an fussballspielen
klieve auf dem werk gehen und deshalb
die sorten wie einfach märkte hoffen
jetzt die möglichkeit dass sie das nur
machen kann
österreichs größter sportler der
gegenwart freut sich auf sein neues
leben
was war sonja wann genau wird kommt man
noch kurz aufs wetter es wird kühler und
wechselhafter in den nächsten tagen mehr
dazu gleich von besten terry 21 uhr 45
kommt das heute journal mit der kollegin
marietta slomka morgen gibt es uns
wieder vom gesamten team 19 danke fürs
zu sehen und in allen ein angenehm haben
[Musik]
ein stück und und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter in den nächsten tagen wird es
kühler denn ein tief bei den britischen
inseln bringt diese kühlere luft zu uns
und so steigen die temperaturen nicht
mehr so stark an wie in den vergangenen
tagen in der nacht gibt es viele wolken
an den küsten und es regnet dazu weder
ein strammer westwind teils stürmisch an
den alpen regnet es aber dieser ring
lässt nach in der mitte klart es auf und
dann gehen die temperaturen ordentlich
zurück bis auf 2 grad örtlich müssen sie
mit bodenfrost rechnen
im süden teils zweistellig um 10 und an
den küsten bei zehn bis elf grad sonst
sind wir im einstelligen bereich
morgen gibt es viel sonnenschein vom
saarland über die mitte nach osten hin
ja im süden da dominieren die wolken und
ganz im norden ist es auch recht bewölkt
an der nordsee kommt mit einem
südwestlichen wind bewölkung auf und es
gibt viel regen
ja und die temperaturen dazu bei 19 bis
21 grad etwa in der mitte
kühler ist es an der nordsee mit 15 bis
17 und 14 grad ganz im süden die
nächsten tage gehen kühl weiter
und dazu gibt es zahlreiche schauer und
gewitter samstag 14 bis 20 grad sonntag
und montag nur noch 11 bis 19 grad
ein schöner abend